[音楽]
こんにちは
無駄に
美容をずっと気にしています始め子達をです開いたけど皆さんも夏ですよね
夏といえをみなさん何が気になりますか
そう匂いです特にメンズとかはこうやっぱ汗をかくと思うんですよね
もちろん僕も夏汗かくんでちょっと匂いが気になったりするんですけども
そんな夏だからこそ
香りで
他のを到達と差をつけたいと思いませんか
まぁ今回の対決は僕じゃないんですけどねはいという名の僕の後輩のかフェチ男がいる
んですけども
この男がですねちょっとあのん
匂いがねぇ
これ以上よねさしてください矢原かく言うと匂いに興味がないんでしょうね多分いう
糸井がないんでさえつ
だからね倉庫で私開いてしまいましたやっぱりおいに興味がない人と思ってればいい
かって考えたところ
もっとシンプルに手短に入って1周ねぇ new になれればいいなと思いましてはい
こちらでございます ax
めっちゃエンジョイするボディスプレーなんですけどもうこの対応ガッツを使ってああ
すげえとを作ります ponta いただくゲートもう
てうまいことなんかこうをした全部アクスが出るようにすればそのもをくぐるだけで
大量の ax が体にかかり
一瞬でいい良いなる
今回はそんな男の湯のようなそうチャックスゲートをつけて書いてると思いません
的な委員10位の男性になったかなと思いますではよって言える ax ゲートを作る
んですけどもやるんならもう本格的なやつを作りたいので僕一人だと作れないんで乗車
の方に作って頂いて作る事にされました
宜しくお願
ブーバーし
[音楽]
妻と言うけど ax ゲートに使って各てこちらのですねエッセンスと披露
こちらの2種類を使っていこうと思いますおおーー
おおーー
た
倒しますと
[音楽]
おっ先物つけるはないんですよ
バックゲートの風
[音楽]
まずすごいありがとうございますクオリティが高すぎでびっくり杯だけで見ていきます
をご覧下さい
ベージュのいっしょじゃっの文字そして両サイドから大量の ax が風邪されるので
ゲートの横にはアクセがしっかりと敷き詰められております
こういう感じで全部スイッチになってるんですよねと下の子が起動生地なっているので
ターグ
人が入ってきて cocco 言って踏めとされて一緒にバーって出る仕組みになって
おりますその実際に住んでいます
幼女君と言います
おりまーす
味すっごい曲ですやばいも匂いが
ヘア石蓮いい匂いで埋め尽くされるというけどちょっとゼコレーションをしてみたんで
だいぶ
アップゲート感は強くなったらなぁと思いますそれで早速ああああゲットを読んでこの
ゲートをくぐるだけでめちゃくちゃいい匂いの男になって
胎教にもてる音方を目指してもらいたいと思いますでは行こう
おっん
ではまた
立っています
よあーいいね勧誘がこう oa じゃないと
針を使って全部避けなくていいそうです
ん
まあねこれえっ扉と雛じゃないと思うんですかこれ
と言う
a
[音楽]
なんとなくわかったぞこれ登録ですか
ん
[音楽]
えっと通ればいっすよねうんきっとはい
とん
まだれ違うぞ
ちょっと族乗ってその上なん
ザブザよって学校センスを全体酒と思いました
caa
ren
うわぁ匂いかいでるに良いズーの
めっちゃ new だよさっほー
ロッカーすごいん
そういうことか変化でねはいお前も出ないと言ってたよなぁ
はあああ youtube さあた攻めがモテない女性営業になって欲しいために
twitter
潜るだけで飲用になれるアクスゲートウェイうわあああっ
すごいこれ結構かかったよねーっ
[音楽]
ブーブー言っ
すごいロサたっ
入ってくる金買いですねこのたためという男いい匂い
そして素敵なを無にするためにラックスゲートをつくってみました
導入したかいや良かったですやもうねぇいい男になってる気がする込んだねって本当に
よ
だー人なんだけどこれからヤードになってから糞使ってるからなああああああああっ
本当に良い大事ですからね今後暮らし気配で ax 今回めっ
じゃあ僕も体見つけたんですけどもうそんな香りもめちゃくちゃ強いわけでもなく結構
自然なハウですごく使いやすかったですね ax いろんな香りのバリエーションが
あるちょっと見ていきましょうか
こちらが気を使ったエッセンス時のですそしてこちらパリをイメージした匂いゴールド
狩りだとよもう
を
[音楽]
ん
あっはっはよいいよ bar パリ行ったことないんでカンパリ来い new ですよ
えっちゃん速いイメージしたスイートな甘いディスティラーになる結構
わー
あーめっちゃないまあこれ好きフルーティーですつけさせばそれはブラック
ニューヨークをイメージした匂いでそれがニューヨークの日だぞね
ああすごいかっこいい匂いがするな
そしてこちらシドニー良い命じたクリックという匂いです
ハーイヨナはやかいスイート
それだけだっていろんな性があるのでぜひ皆さん自分が好きなのに良いノア[ __ ]を使って
みてください
そしてですね何度キャンペーンのスタッフがございますサックスの講師がツイッターを
フォロー
そしてキャンペーン用のツイートをリツイートして下さったからな
あっいますよそしてキャンペーンのツイート立一してくださった方の中から抽選で10
名様に
ax 限定の肇社長の追求をプレゼントいたします
汚水管を支払うを飯食わせないでは動画の概要欄にありますぜひ皆さんそちらを
チェックしてください
アックスを使って素敵なにおいで夏を過ごしてみてください
じゃん
[音楽]
me
バッハ
ほんと使い7本当になあなたいいねしたらいいよ本当に問題通っとーさーんつ考えどう
かも使えない